in this lesson we're going to talk about
the phrase in terms of so basically what
this is talking about when they say
write something in terms of we're
basically rewriting an equation to get
one variable in terms of
other variables and constants etc so
you're trying to isolate that one
variable and get it in terms of
something else so let's go through a
couple examples see if you can pause the
video do these on your own we'll go
through them together it says given the
equation that 3x minus 2y equals 12
write y in terms of x so see how it says
write y in terms of x that means they
want us to get this y by itself so y
equals
something else so what we're going to do
is we're going to just try to
work from the outside in towards this
variable y by doing the opposite so i'm
going to subtract 3x from both sides
okay so that gives us negative 2y equals
negative 3x plus 12 okay and then what i
want to do to get this y by itself is do
the opposite of multiplying by negative
2 i want to divide everything by
negative 2. so now we get y equals
positive 3 halves x minus 6. so now you
can see y is in terms of
x and constants okay so you've got the y
by itself example number two it says
express w in terms of y
for all real numbers w x and y
such that w equals x to the fourth and y
equals x squared so here what they're
telling us okay if we reread it again is
that we want to get w
in terms of y so we want to solve for w
and we want to get it in terms of you
know just y on the other side of the
equation so we got to isolate that w so
let's start off with what they give us
which is w equals x to the fourth this
is w in terms of x but we want w in
terms of y
so if we look over here y equals x
squared if we square both sides you can
see that y squared equals
x to the fourth power right so what we
can do now is since x to the fourth
equals y squared we can put y squared in
place of x to the fourth so you can see
w equals
y squared so now we have w in terms of y
and you've got it so definitely
something important to understand you
know this terminology in terms of uh
just isolate that variable and put it in
terms of other variables or other
constants and you got it i'll see you in
the next lesson